washington journal continues
we're joined by author garrett graf who
has a brand new book out just came out
yesterday called watergate a new history
garrett graf
we mentioned before you came on this is
the 50th anniversary this year of
watergate but why now a new history for
watergate
so the story that we have sort of long
remembered from watergate you know as
passed down to us through the robert
redford dustin hoffman movie all the
president's men uh actually turns out to
not be really what happened um and so my
goal with this book was
to
ahead of the 50th anniversary of the
break-in this year try to pull together
all of the things that we have learned
over the last 50 years about what really
happened in that story
watergate of course is something that
has been sliced and diced in a thousand
different ways by
uh all sorts of authors but no one has
sat down to write a start to finish soup
to nuts narrative history like this in a
quarter century
and since then we've learned all sorts
of new facts that are really pertinent
and and changed the way
that we believe that this story actually
unfolded um
the the revelation of the identity of
deep throat fbi director
fbi deputy director mark felt the
release of the nixon tapes the release
of the papers around
the chanault affair which i'm sure we'll
we'll talk about um over the course of
this conversation um one of the key
triggering events of the whole scandal
and one that until relatively recently
most people didn't realize was linked to
watergate at all the declassification of
all manner of documents i mean we we
think of watergate as sort of this one
moment this burglary at the democratic
national committee offices in june of
1972
but when you dive into it when you fully
understand the history what watergate
turns out to be is a mindset it's this
uh
criminal uh abusive uh
power uh mindset that permeates the
nixon white house permeates his inner
and outer circles of a bunch of really
strange characters who populate the
white house um during his time
and
lead to really what is a dozen
inter-related
but distinct scandals from the chenalta
fair to the houston plan uh to itt and
the deeda beard memo the milk producers
donations
the vesco donation i mean at the end of
watergate 69 people will have been
indicted and
including actually new york yankees
owner george steinbrenner i mean i
figure most people don't realize was
associated with the watergate scandal at
all let's make sure we open up our phone
lines to hear from viewers on this brand
new book by garrett graf
on watergate 2027 48 8001 the line for
republicans 2027 488 000
for democrats and 202 748 8002
for independence and others let me ask
our director to bring that the cover of
the book up on the screen again and i
want to ask you
uh what is that thing in the on the on
the front page of that book and why did
you put it there on the cover so this is
you know the center piece of the whole
scandal this is one of the recording
machines
that helped to capture
all of the conversations that took place
in richard nixon's oval office um in uh
in camp david in parts of the residence
his telephone lines his
hideaway office in the old executive
office building um
and it's the revelation of those tapes
uh in the summer of
1973 a full year into the scandal
that really changes the directory the
changes the trajectory
of the entire scandal um and that final
year of the scandal from uh basically
july
1973 through nixon's resignation in
august 1974 is really the battle for
those tapes to learn
what parts of this crime
and criminality um and abuses of power
were captured
uh in richard nixon's own words on those
recordings how much time do you spend
either listening to the tapes or reading
the transcripts of those tapes well the
the tapes have come out uh piecemeal
over the years um it's been the subject
of a long-running battle
between uh stanley
cutler um a
historian who really helped force the
first set of tapes out
uh in the late 1990s
and then more so in the um
more volumes have come out um douglas
brinkley and luke nichter
published two successive volumes of the
tapes um in the last couple of years a
huge benefit to historians
because the tapes themselves are
actually a total mess um
and it's noteworthy that the nixon
library and the national archives have
never put out definitive transcripts of
their own they have always left this to
historians to interpret because the the
tapes are such a audio
uh mess um you know
they are
relatively primitive recording
technology and so some of the voices are
hard to hear
the recording devices were actually set
in the president's desk surface itself
the secret service actually drilled
holes up from the bottom of the
the the president's desk so that the
microphones sat just below the surface
of the table and so anything that
happens on the table sounds like an
explosion i mean someone sets down a
coffee cup
and it sounds like a car crash you know
nixon like to put his feet up on the
table uh uh
put his feet up on the desk and you know
when he does that it sounds like a bomb
going off and so the tapes are
enormously hard to listen to and
historians uh like stanley cutler and
and luke nichter and douglas brinkley
have done an incredible benefit to our
country to decipher these over the years
so president nixon on in on that
basically expanded on what president
johnson had in terms of recording phone
conversations
why did president nixon want everything
recorded in the oval office yeah and
this begins to teach you something about
the psychology of richard nixon um you
know he is this
fascinating character um you know
really in some ways richard nixon is the
man on which the entire hinge of america
in the 20th century turns um and you
have
uh this turn from you know the new deal
great society politics that preceded him
to
you know the age of reagan that followed
him and
that richard nixon sees himself as this
incredibly transformative president um
and he was as a political figure he he's
he was on the the republicans national
ticket five times
in the course of the 20th century um a
record tied only by democrat fdr
he was on time magazine
cover 55 times i mean more than a full
year of time magazine covers featured
richard nixon over the course of his
career
and so he comes into office
uh
the first thing he does is actually tear
out the recording system
that lyndon johnson had in place and he
wants nothing to do with it then as his
presidency begins to unfold
what effectively happens is that he
fears
that he is not going to get credit for
his great achievements
and that
people aides like henry kissinger are
going to steal all of the credit for his
big decisions um his big moments of
history um and he particularly begins to
feel this as he sees someone like henry
kissinger you know say one thing in the
oval office and then whisper something
else at the cocktail parties in georg in
georgetown um and that uh you know henry
kissinger is a hawk inside the oval
office and a dove at cocktail parties
and so nixon uh gets frustrated that he
just feels like the true history of his
presidency is not being captured and so
he
has the secret service install this
secret recording system known to
virtually no one inside his own
administration and so all of these
figures sort of come through
his oval office come through the
residents come through his hideaway
never understanding that they are being
recorded
and it's not until alex butterfield one
of the oval office aides tells the
senate watergate committee in july of
1973 that this recording system exists
that uh
everyone now understands that all of
these conversations that they've had
with nixon have actually been captured
and then the battle begins about whether
those tapes should actually be turned
over to investigators eric graf is our
guest the book watergate a new history
welcome your calls and comments
202-748-8001 for republicans 2027 488
000 for democrats and
all others 202 748 8002 and just a
sample from that book you you write kind
of touching on what you said about
president nixon you said at its simplest
you wrote at its simplest watergate is
the story of two separate criminal
conspiracies the nixon world's dirty
tricks that led to the burglar in
january 17 1972 and then the subsequent
wider cover-up the first conspiracy was
deliberate islamic a sloppy shambolic
but nonetheless developed plan to
subvert the 1972 election the second was
reactive almost instinctive it seemed to
happen simply because no one said new no
one said no garrett graf
richard nixon
didn't suffer any legal consequences
from watergate he was pardoned by gerald
ford after he came into office
what could have happened to richard
nixon legally
yeah it's a great question um
and one of course that looms a lot over
our modern discourse i mean part of i
think what makes this story
so relevant to us even 50 years later is
the way that we have watched the
scandals of the trump administration
unfold over the last five years
and
uh think about the consequences to some
of those high-level officials um you
know in some ways the entire battle that
we have seen between donald trump and
joe biden over the last couple of uh
weeks and months over executive
privilege traces directly back to
watergate it was a it was watergate that
established for the first time the idea
that and codified the uh the existence
of executive privilege in the first
place as nixon asserted executive
privilege over those tapes that we've
been discussing
ultimately that was turned aside by the
supreme court the tapes were released uh
and uh the so-called smoking pistol
conversation uh helped to lead to
richard nixon's resignation in august 74
ahead of what were expected to be two
articles of impeachment
that the house was going to bring
to a vote and then
pass on to the senate for trial
nixon resigns ahead of all of that as
you said
and then gerald ford uh pardons him just
a few weeks later uh
basically making the calculation that
even though
ford understands that it might cost him
uh election in 76
that he's not going to be able to govern
as president if
the the former president's legal
troubles are continuing to unfold
now the full scope of richard nixon's
crimes and his administration's crimes
uh took a long time for us to learn um
you know part of uh
you know the mythology that i take on in
in this book is that washington has
learned this maxim um you've probably
had guests say it on this show before
the cover-up is always worse than the
crime
which is to many people the lesson of
watergate um that if richard nixon had
just come clean hung g gordon liddy um
and e howard hunt and
maybe john mitchell jeb magruder or a
couple of other officials out to dry
maybe his presidency could have survived
but the truth of the matter is richard
nixon's crimes were quite bad
there were many of them
and that they unfolded across a wide
range of uh outright criminality
illegality uh and presidential abuses of
power including abuses of civil
liberties and privacy of american
citizens
and i i do want you to touch on in a
little bit more about g gordon lydia and
how a man like that got involved in the
nixon campaign but we've got calls
waiting for you garrett graf let's go
first to william in union west virginia
good morning democrats line
uh yes sir um i just had a question
with the 50th anniversary here
what what the relevancy
of the next nixon administration
compared to
the clinton administration as spying on
a sitting u.s president
and
then candidate president and how how
that would factor in and the similar
similarities of it
and just uh just a comment from you
yeah and thank you
so you know obviously this is a story
that has been unfolding in these this
last week the this idea um
that the
john durham who is investigating the
early stages of the trump russia
investigation
uh
has put out um
this idea that there was some sort of
spy effort against the trump white house
um that's actually not what john durham
the u.s attorney the the special
prosecutor in this case has actually
said um and that uh the
this has gotten sort of twisted up um
amplified in uh right-wing media
incorrectly
um and conflated a bunch of things and
conflated a bunch of timelines and that
when you untangle it
what it actually looks like is that this
was a
that there was sort of a longer standing
effort
actually during the obama administration
so pre-trump uh to study russian malware
uh and russian-focused internet traffic
that was unfolding um in washington
around the white house in the executive
office of the presidency um which is
sort of the formal governmental
structure of
the management structure in which the
presidency unfolds do you think since
watergate and since the investigative
journalism that happened that people
that americans pretty much expect
scandal in other words they kind of
suspect scandal at least being around
the corner
uh in government
yeah
absolutely and and this is where in many
ways the legacy of watergate has changed
washington which is when you look at how
journalism now treats large institutions
i mean this moment of the vietnam war of
the pentagon papers of watergate in the
1970s uh
really heralds a sea change in the way
that america views its government views
its president and the way that the press
treats covering government that that you
had this sort of tradition of scribes uh
really before
nixon and and then
uh the investigative journalists who
tackled watergate um really ushered in
this new style
of much more aggressive much more
questioning much more investigative
reporting that we have seen against the
presidency uh and all manner of other
government institutions um it also in
many ways actually
creates the modern structure of the
freedom of information act um and
privacy laws um and oversight of the
intelligence agencies
um whose abuses of power were caught up
in the watergate story as well and so
much of what we now know
about
you know what goes wrong in government
we can trace back to the legacy of
richard nixon and watergate back to
calls and tom is in tampa florida
republican line
uh yes gentlemen thank you very much uh
for allowing me to call uh my question
was i was born and raised in d.c and as
a matter of fact my i was married in the
morning in june 1772 but my question is
concerning g gordon lenny
i used to listen to his radio show
years ago when he had his radio show and
he would uh
always purport that uh john dean had
something to do with the uh
break-in assembly because of the fact
that he was trying to retrieve damaging
information uh
they were trying to uh get damaging
information on john dean's uh wife
maureen is is there is there any truth
to that or can you elaborate on that and
i'll hang up and listen yeah this is
actually is part of one of the great
mysteries of of the watergate story you
know that for all the attention that we
have ever paid to watergate for all
of the investigations that unfolded for
all of those 69 separate sets of
indictments
that i mentioned came out of the story
no one has ever been prosecuted or
charged with
ordering the break-in itself
and that there are a swirl of different
theories and and different stories that
have grown up over the last 50 years
about what those burglars were actually
doing
inside the democratic national committee
offices on the morning of june 17th
1972. um
and some of that has to do with the the
plans that unfolded um before then
um you know most americans for instance
don't realize that the burglary that
night was the second burglary of the
watergate
the the burglars had actually been in a
couple of weeks earlier
and screwed up and so they were coming
back to try to fix at least some of the
problems that unfolded um in
uh in that first burglary
and so uh
you know there
there's sort of this uh official theory
that that was this very shambolic
third-rate burglary which is what
nixon's
uh
press secretary calls
the events a few days later
and then there's a swirl of other
stories about and theories about other
people uh who may have had reason to
order the burglars in that night um the
potential role
of uh put maybe even the cia attempting
to sabotage the burglary um and that
there are a lot of still very open
questions about what transpired that
night
in part because uh
it could be true that there are sort of
multiple things unfolding at once that
there's reason to believe
that there were multiple motives
among the burglars that night unknown to
each other it could have been g gordon
liddy and howard hunt were just
freelancing i mean you write that you
about this complete set of plans all
sorts of
other activities the the gemstone plan
you write about could they have just
said this is this is this is part of
that and we're going they hired the
burglars for example
yeah and this becomes uh
you know as you mentioned uh
america sort of has this idea that
because
the burglary is when we learned of these
dirty tricks that that was the beginning
of the events but the the truth of the
matter is this was really like america
walking into the second or third act of
a play with no knowledge that it had
been going on for months earlier and so
what you saw with richard nixon uh and g
gordon liddy is that those dirty tricks
had been unfolding for more than a year
before the
uh the burglary that night and sort of
trying to understand all of the
different motives all of the different
players
has consumed historians for half a
century
let's hear from high point north
carolina betty
on the democrats line you're on go ahead
good morning thank you for taking my
call mr graf i have been over the last
few years i've been going back
trying to find out about watergate and
looking at a lot of the testimony
and things online
and what i was really concerned about
was the way that martha mitchell was
treated by john mitchell that she had
reminders
and that she was drugged is do you do
you deal with any of that in your book
yeah this actually becomes a big part of
the book um
as we look back on it 50 years later
with a much clearer set of eyes
martha mitchell
the incredibly outspoken uh and wildly
famous
wife of then attorney general john
mitchell john mitchell the campaign
chief for nixon in 68 then becomes
attorney general then leaves attorney
general to become the campaign chief for
72 forced out right after the burglary
um
and that the relationship of john and
martha mitchell becomes
one of the seminal threads of the
watergate scandal
um
martha mitchell was in many ways the
first famous conservative pundit in
american history she
uh this uh
the the so-called mouth of the south
this wildly outspoken woman from
uh arkansas with a habit of calling up
uh reporters like helen thomas late at
night and dishing about what was going
on inside the nixon administration
she was the most in-demand speaker in
the country
for republicans uh
other than richard nixon himself
and she was
this key figure
in part because she's a deeply tragic
figure um
she becomes uh depressed she's has a
problem with alcohol
um
and uh is deeply unhappy in her life in
washington
uh as john mitchell's spouse
their relationship unravels uh
dramatically in the weeks after
watergate
in part because john mitchell tries to
hide the truth of what had happened at
the watergate from martha mitchell
because he fears
that
she will speak to the press
and
that she
uh
as the caller mentioned she was actually
drugged against her will in california a
few days after the burglary she ends up
in
new york state sort of in hiding
and that she and john mitchell
never speak again
and
end up separating
and ultimately divorcing um and she dies
soon after richard nixon's resignation
let's hear from glenn in california
lancaster california
hi glenn good morning
good morning
mr garrett
we we're using we're not using our
common sense we have a very corrupt
government for all these years
and hillary clinton played a part in the
watergate thing
and we watched
as
a duly elected president donald trump
would sabotage his whole presidency
through russia collusion through
impeachment
and we're not being representative by a
const or constitutional republic we keep
screaming to our democracy our democracy
it's these corrupt
people that have been in place for 50
years
taking our freedoms away not
representing the people representing
themselves through the cia through the
fbi
through
the mueller report we had to wait for
and through c-span we should have a
direct line to our representatives and
we should be represented as a free
country
glad glad you got through on the line
glenn uh garrett graf any comments yeah
so this uh you know
one of the most amazing parts of the
watergate story is realizing the role of
all of these players who are still with
us today
as the caller mentioned
hillary
rodham was actually a young attorney uh
part of the investigating team
uh for the house impeachment committee
alongside john dorr
and that there are uh you know this is
sort of in some ways where she gets her
starts in politics um the she was
already dating
uh bill clinton uh and he had been tried
to be recruited onto the committee uh
and he said well i'm gonna go back to
arkansas and try to run for governor but
you should hire my girlfriend hillary
and she ends up being part of this
committee roger stone another figure
from modern day politics who ends up a
big part of the watergate dirty tricks
operation
and that
as the caller mentioned
you see these big institutions the fbi
and the cia coming into play in this
story
and that that's one of the ways that
this book really i think helps to
rewrite the story of what we understood
took place in watergate because no one
until this book has tried to put in
context what it means that deep throat
was actually fbi associate director
effectively the deputy director of the
fbi uh mark felt and so that is a single
fact that actually radically rewrites
our understanding of what was actually
taking place in washington from 72 to 74
because
what we see is that the way that mark
felt's leaks
were aimed not at richard dixon but
actually at trying to sink the acting
fbi director patrick gray
and that
you know this idea that deep throat was
this you know
anti-nixon insider uh trying to fight
for good government uh actually doesn't
really hold up um because what we see is
that mark felt is uh doing some
self-serving bureaucratic knife fighting
to try to get the top job at the fbi
himself
and that this becomes one of the key
storylines that
we are only now understanding
with a full sweep of history moving from
1972 to 1973 and the watergate the
senate watergate committee hearings what
do you view as the
the long-term the first for the short
term what was the effect of those
hearings and the long-term
effect on
how that hearing that committee shaped
the future congressional investigations
yeah it's a great question and obviously
one that's super relevant to
c-span and its mission and our view of
the work that congress does because uh
sam ervin's committee as it comes
together over the course of the spring
of 1973 the the watergate select
committee
is stepping into at the time new
territory there is almost no history
until that point
of meaningful congressional oversight
congressional investigations of the
executive branch
when james hamilton one of the members
of the team goes back to look through
the history
for the analogs of what congress was
trying to do what the urban committee
was trying to do
he points actually to
the congress's investigation of the
debacle at the battle of bull run
in 1861 you know a hundred and ten years
earlier there's just not that many
uh examples for him to pull from
and so that urban committee really
establishes for the first time
aggressive congressional oversight of
the executive branch
and also uh creates this moment of
must-see tv
in american history um where that summer
of 73 you know if you talk to almost
anyone who is alive that at that time
they will talk about you know what a big
deal those wall-to-wall tv coverage of
those hearings turned out to be in that
moment
the average american household over the
course of the summer of 1973 watches
almost 40 hours of the irvin committee
you know basically a full work week
worth of committee hearings aired live
on abc nbc cbs
um and and public television
in the evenings and that that becomes
it makes stars out of the irving
committee it makes stars out of people
like john dean
uh
and his blockbuster testimony early in
the uh or early in the hearings and
really helps to begin to change the
nation's perception of watergate all
right let's get to more calls sunderland
maryland next up larry on the
independent line
yes uh you don't mention that two of the
burglars were uh e howard hunt and frank
sturgis and the security officer that
captured whether the first or the second
he could not find work and
there was a operative for the cia he was
approached to assassinate nixon but he
said he wouldn't do it because it was
friends i think he had a code named
gizmo cosmo and the reason why ford
pardoned next thing because nexon is a
book called nixon secrets nixon was
going to reveal about what happened in
dallas because nixon was there november
21st he he was with he was a you know uh
counselor with pepsi so forth so that's
some things that uh you should check on
nixon nixon's secrets garrett graf yeah
and this this becomes part of this whole
question of whether the cia uh had a
role in
watergate
either
knowledge of or an attempt even to
sabotage the burglary perhaps
trying to sink the burglary and get the
burglars arrested
there's good evidence to believe that
the cia had
much deeper knowledge of nixon's dirty
tricks than they let on
e howard hunt
the former cia officer one of the
burglars
one of the other burglars
came out of the cuban emigre population
in miami that linked to the bay of pigs
was actively on the cia payroll as a
asset 100 a month asset um on the night
of the burglary and reported back to his
handlers through the the whole time that
he was working on the sort of dirty
tricks team that g gordon liddy and
howard hunt pulled together and of
course then there are some weird moments
where gordon liddy uh in his role as
part of the plumbers working in the
nixon white house turns to the cia for
help
the cia provides him with a disguise for
their burglary of daniel ellsberg
psychiatrists office in the fall
of 1970
1971
after the pentagon papers are released
and that uh they the cia actually
develops film that gordon liddy
has taken um
during one of his stakeouts of
ellsberg's psychiatrist's office uh and
then actually most weird of all uh g
gordon liddy when he comes up with his
grand uh operation gemstone plan for the
re-election dirty tricks this
million-dollar operation uh you know
that involves uh in his mind you know uh
uh
hiring prostitutes to seduce uh
democratic officials uh spy planes
uh burglaries like what we actually see
in watergate um
at the dnc offices um he turns to the
cia to have him make to have them make
up the charts
of these highly illegal plans and so you
know at almost every step the cia is
much more deeply aware of what is taking
place amid the crime and criminality of
richard nixon than uh
than we understood at the time that's uh
next up is uh hernan virginia samantha
on the independent line
good morning thank you so much for being
on and i look forward to um reading your
book on this as a lifelong red sox fan i
have to know
what was george steinbrenner's
involvement in this
[Laughter]
so one of the big things that becomes
part of the watergate scandal this sort
of umbrella as i describe it of these
you know dozen interlocking uh scandals
that unfolds is this rush of
illegal campaign finance uh uh of the
nixon campaign these illegal donations
many of them in cash
uh funneled to the nixon campaign in the
spring of 72
amid
some changing campaign finance laws
and george steinbrenner uh
and his company uh actually end up being
caught up in making some of those
illegal donations um and these records
have really only come out in the last
couple of years the fbi files released
after george steinbrenner's death so we
have for the first time a good
understanding of george steinbrenner's
role in the midst of all this but as i
said you know this was this was a case
where there were dozens of american
corporations caught up in this illegal
financing scheme from american airlines
to goodyear tire
many of them face many of their
corporate executives faced criminal
charges as well uh all part of that
total of 69 people
eventually indicted for charges stemming
from watergate and all of its associated
scandals we'll hear from bill in
arlington heights illinois republican
line
good morning gentlemen i have a question
for garrett are you familiar with jeff
shepard's new book the nixon conspiracy
watergate and the plot to remove the
president
yes i am
and if you are what is i have not read
the book yet but the author worked in
the nixon white house and he claims that
documents that he has seen and uncovered
indicates that
for the lack of a better word nixon was
set up by a variety of people within the
government including the prosecutor's
office
yeah and this this becomes part of how
the nixon's story the watergate story
has shifted and unfolded
over the last 50 years is that there has
been a lot of
recent scholarship in the last 20 or 30
years
trying to really reimagine richard nixon
as the victim of watergate rather than
the perpetrator thereof
um and this idea that he
um that figures like al haig his chief
of staff
uh you know helped force him from office
in the end um and
uh
there are reasons to believe sort of
parts of that story um but as i said
earlier in the hour uh
richard nixon's paranoid dark mindset
and his uh you know pervasive
criminality
is clear
and very much predates
the burglary and the cover-up itself so
i i think the there there's sort of a
way to look at this that is the question
of what transpires before the night of
june uh 17th 1972 when the burglars are
arrested and what transpires after
um and
it is certainly clear that at least
before 19 uh between before that night
in june 1972
nixon was the perpetrator of the mindset
and the crimes and the abuses of power
that led to that night and those arrests
how helpful to you in your research was
the nixon library in california well the
nixon library
has a very complex relationship with
watergate um and it's been uh this long
running
battle um between actually the the
president uh when he was alive um he he
he originally wanted to
get his tapes and burn them after his
presidency
and the national archives has really
fought for decades to try to preserve
the full story
of the nixon uh
the nixon impeachment watergate the
nixon presidency
and it's only been relatively recently
um really under the leadership of then
nixon library director uh
tim naphtali
that we have seen
the
the those keepers of the nixon legacy
wrestle with
uh nixon's true legacy um and now
uh the watergate story is actually the
single largest exhibit at the nixon
library but there's still a lot of
uh
uncomfortableness
about how to confront and tell the story
of watergate among nixon loyalists let's
get a couple more calls first is kevin
in san antonio texas good morning
hey good morning thank you for taking my
call uh
i think that what i want the guests to
explain is how complex politics is and
nixon was a politician you know what i'm
saying and that nixon did a lot of good
things there's a lot of bad things but
you know just explain to people how
politicians are and they do the same
thing today
yeah and and this i think is one of the
things that makes
watergate fascinating to us half a
century later richard nixon fascinating
to us a half century later
is it's this mix of the light and the
dark
the idea that in many ways
had watergate never happened richard
nixon would still be among the most
consequential presidents of the 20th
century he was the first president to
visit a
communist country the first to visit
moscow the first to visit china
you know as part of his famous reopening
of relationships with china he wound
down the vietnam war he created the
environmental protection agency
um he signed title ix legislation um and
in many ways really changed the face of
the country and yet all of that is now
shorthanded uh with you know this
scandal that has come to define all
other scandals as watergate and what
what's more in 72 he was not really
threatened by the democratic candidate
was who was um
72 was
george mcgovern correct exactly i mean
he wins re-election in in 72 by the
largest landslide
in american presidential history um and
and that is part of the deep irony and
tragedy of watergate is that all of
these dirty tricks that he launched to
try to
uh
uh you know shape the 72 election were
probably not needed at all and he could
have coasted to reelection
even without any of them let's hear from
joe in terre haute indiana independent
line
good morning uh c-span thank you so much
for what you do uh mr graf uh may i
first asked a very uh personal question
what year were you born sir i was born
81
okay
let me say this
what was your purpose of writing this
book mr graf other than i know it's
always good to make some money and
you're very
good at what you do but i can't figure
out where you're coming from mr graf
i see a lot of parallels between the
trump administration and the nixon
administration and i just like to know
uh where do you come from what is the
purpose of this book will it help us at
this time when our democracy is being
threatened
uh
where where are you at on that all right
joe let's uh let's let's hear from our
yeah it's a great question and i'm so
glad you asked it because this is this
actually is an important part of the
story is that i as a journalist
have spent the last five six years
covering
uh russia's attack on the 2016 election
the mueller investigation everything
that has unfolded as part of that
and
uh what we have seen is this paralysis
in our politics this polarization and
partisanship in our politics over the
last five years
um and so what i wanted to do was to
take this question of presidential
abuses of power
and go back to a moment when washington
worked
because
watergate as i say in the book is in
many ways the greatest story ever told
of how power unfolds in washington
and it is this moment when you see all
of the institutions of america
of american government the press the
justice department the executive branch
the special prosecutors the courts the
house the senate all come together to
force this criminal and corrupt
president from office and so washington
worked in this moment from 72 to 74 and
you see all of the ways that the checks
and balances of our constitution come
together the way that article one of the
constitution works with article two
works with article three to achieve this
larger goal of protecting our democracy
and protecting our government and so for
me this telling this story today
is about looking back at a moment in
washington history when our government
worked and succeeded and so i wanted to
tell that story using this lens of
presidential abuses of power as a way to
sort of reflect the events that we have
lived through over the last five years
as i said to someone uh you know donald
trump's name actually appears only once
in the text of this book
but he looms and his presidency looms
almost over almost every page of it
interested what's the context that
donald trump has mentioned in your book
well that
that he is mentioned in the context of
the change that richard nixon brings to
the republican party that richard
nixon's southern strategy um
begets this turn towards sort of
racialized
uh
nationalist
anti-immigrant
politics that really finds its natural
conclusion in 2016 with the nomination
and election of donald trump okay here's
randall in metairie louisiana
hi
i have a few reflections on
what the author is saying i was in
college when this happened
and
i remember seeing the televised
hearings
i think that they should be doing that
yesterday
with
the former president
but i would say that
a lot of the
acolytes and defenders
of trump
have been on over the years particularly
william garment
who i called in when you had him on
c-span many years ago
and he was
talking about how richard nixon
should have never been prosecuted
and i had a simple question for him
if the people in the united states knew
about richard nixon in 1972
what they found out about him in 1973
would they have voted for him i will
leave it there uh randall uh garrett
graff any comments on that or some final
thoughts here yeah and this is uh you
know i think a big part of looking back
at this story is what it can teach us in
this moment um and you know i think the
irvin committee the rodino committee
uh really have a lot of lessons for
the january 6 committee as it unfolds
and as it works to try to bring to light
the truth of what transpired on january
6th
and in that contested election um in
2020 um and so you know this this to me
is a book that uses this lens of history
to tell us a lot about what our modern
times in politics
can be and should be and what we should
be looking to our leaders to be doing at
this moment it's the new book on water
break watergate a new history
from garrett graff great to have you
with us this morning on washington
journal it's always a pleasure to talk
to you thank you so much for having me
that will do it for this morning's
program we are back tomorrow morning at
7 a.m eastern here on washington journal
and hope you are too and enjoy the rest
of your day
[Music]
you